on va accueillir tout de suite à nouveau
dans l'émission qui s'appelle andreas
alors il a déjà fait un pilote avec nous
vous le dis il s'intéresse à tout ce qui
se passe dans les séries et série bien
pourri et puis il va dans la rue pour
voilà voir ce qui se passe au niveau de
l'actualité est avec nous ce soir
andreas et les blues
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la fin il sait déjà il a un prénom
bien y regarder de quelle origine
grecque
j'adore c'est que j'adore les grecs mois
vous en connaissez d'autres biens chauny
n'est que de mykonos et connus de leurs
voix y on est comme ça a été gravement
mais bien sûr je mange de la feta
pratiquement tous les soirs c'est quoi
ton nom de famille castaignos castries
noël c'est signé du coup à l'aller pas
le bon on dirait une ligue 1 qui suivait
c'est au choix castries où la belle
époque bicoque la bac c'est pile ce à
côté tu as à deux pas de santorin écoute
s'il n'a fait tout les igg regrets clap
atos cette année j'ai envie de me
laisser porter par les dernières on est
allé au club de vacances ou qui a tout
intérêt ce qui m'intéresse aux séries
mais alors surtout aux séries que
personne ne regarde problème c'est que
le bdr a voulu savoir pourquoi personne
ne regardait ses séries et je crois que
j'ai comme un début de réponse à la je
suis passé sur idf1 sur la série la
reine blanche et vous allez voir dans la
séquence qui sort que peut-être pas
après ça vous allez voir dans la
séquence qui suit l'acteur principal a
eu comme une envie pressante mais la
séquence quand même c'est que le gars du
zap et qu'il était filmé quoi j'adore
cette série nous attendons le verdict
majesté excusez moi je veux pisser
savoir que l'acteur principal l'acteur
qui apparaît à l'image dans un 70 ans
mais le gars qu'il doubla doit avoir 16
ans et demi mais c'est ricardo comment
ça va ce matin toi cette heure mais tout
ce qui à monsieur ricordeau je trouve ça
très bien tu veux prendre un petit
déjeuner des yeux avec du lard je suis
passé sur les mystères de l'amour à leur
niveau scénario c'est pas hollywood mais
même quand les acteurs doivent chier
c'est forcément tu dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon ben ali vous rigolez mais c'était
michael jackson dans thriller jackson
c'est cris qui est lui en fait il était
assistant ont fait à la base et ils ont
fait jouer mais voilà il est dans la cei
doit du coup un peu que c'est là le
premier extrait des bars bien celui-ci a
alors enchaîné du coup une petite
barbichette un bail à trois points des
sharks on enchaîne choses s'y passent et
bien sûr les téléfilm de m6 l'après midi
je suis assez sûr cattier son prince
charmant alors qu'ati pour son premier
délit avec son prince charmant a décidé
de vérité dans un resto dans noir c'est
sympa et un peu de mystère on ne voit
pas problème c'est que master serie 5 at
il son prince charmant ça existe mais je
sais que c'est un peu moins sympa parce
que dans le noir on voit pas non plus
qu'on mange la sa désertion peut-être
une soupe ou recommencer à ça m'a l'air
très bien oui les plaisirs je préfère
entendre les gens avant de les voir en
même temps le physique c'est quand aussi
[Applaudissements]
ok le gorge pour le dire est qu'elle
encore la mousse du bain fort la
regarder ce que je fais tomber on a
récupéré un contrat de dalcin vous le
dit le société tf1 productions germé
encore rien je vous le dirai tout à
l'heure bim attention est ce que la télé
c'est magouille et compagnie on verrait
sa twitter j'ai pas peur de délai pour
faire le dossier série je suis aussi
passé je vous ai amené la pépite je suis
passé sur sister je suis passé sur si
près de chez vous la série oscarisée en
bas alors attention éloigné bien les
enfants du poste parce que je vous ai
ramené la scène de bagarre la plus
violente de tous coeur battait torride
bien contente de rencontrer un homme
comme lui mais non mais j'ai en quatre
coups d'avancé
[Musique]
yu
alors très long on sera pas comme ça
mais moi j'ai déjà vu ça dans un cours
de krav maga
souvent ça se finit sur une civière
annoncés dont je ne sais où ça oscar de
la direccte comme ça le matin moi je
regarde ah oui tous les matchs on adore
va bien vous aussi vous avez besoin
michel est logique et 12h01 heure ses
vrais débuts travailler pour les bruits
tout à l'heure bravo je le prouverai
tout en arriver à une très grosse info
sur france télévisions ça c'est vraiment
toi tu crois pas mais tu vas voir si
j'ai des infos un petit peu je me suis
aussi basé sur l'actuelle alors là
dessus en ce moment c'était la fiac je
sais la fiac à la foire internationale
de l'art contemporain où qu'ils soient
chaque année j'ai vu en plus y avait
autre chose dit non ça c'était la fnac
c'est la fnac
[Musique]
j'ai voulu un petit peu sont des lieux
artistiques des français pour l'occasion
bas j'ai créé ma propre oeuvre d'art
j'ai pris deux objets dans une poubelle
je les ai assemblée je les ai mis bas
parmi les autres oeuvres d'art et vous
allez voir que dans ce genre
d'événements tout le monde on a dit
super engagé sur la question et
saint-marin le hier je pense l'horizon
bouché
quand les enfants maintenant papineau
twins ok c'est pour alerter le peuple
contre l'avortement c'est pour les
enfants jetés comme des dans les
toilettes comme des étrons meilleur je
trouve ça très très puissante et il va
avoir des problèmes dans futur des
problèmes de quoi d'un transit
c'est un enfant constipé corps des
enfants un peu maltraités non certains
pays qui n'ont pas ce dont ce dont ils
ont besoin
[ __ ] je laisse traîner n'importe quoi
n'importe où sans dire
[Applaudissements]
pas fini alors du coup moi j'ai commencé
à faire et un petit peu le potentiel de
mon oeuvre je me suis dit il ya
peut-être moyen de faire un billet alors
j'ai dit qu'elle était d'un artiste
japonais de la nouvelle vague je vais
trouver un nom bien japonais problème
c'est qu'en français et rendait moins
bien je m'en suis pas rendu compte tout
de suite est ce que vous connaissez
d'artistes coller au cul l'artiste
japonais danois n'a que vous allez au
coût que ça ne parle puis ça me fait
quelque chose qu'il aurait déjà vu mais
je pense au grand palais avril s'ils
n'améliorent pas ce que avoir dit ça
c'est un artiste japonais met tout de
suite je vais aller voir sur internet
parce que franchement c'est très très
intéressant ce qui fait coller au cul ça
colle au cul pour ne jamais j'avais
vendu fondateur cheikh 3000 euros dix
mille en euros au delà de 1000 euros je
sais pas c'est qu'on est là quand même
combien ça coûte ça peut je ne paierai
pas plus de vandales
[Applaudissements]